هما تلميذه في مدرسه حكوميه في العاصمه
كابول كانت تنتظر ان تفتح المدرسه ابوابها
اليوم امامها وامام زميلاتها الا انها
تيقنت ان انتظارها وانتظار زميلاتها قد
يطول
ان
يذهب والمدارس ولكننا نحن لم نستطيع
الذهاب الى الدراسه مع الاسف الشديد
زيبا معلمه في مدرسه في كابول درست اليوم
فتيانا دون الفتيات تطالب السلطات
الافغانيه بتقديم فرص التعليم للفتيات
ايضا فصل الربيع قد بدا دعوا البراعم
تتفتح والا تذبل بحسب تعبيرها
زانو الرجل والمراه في المجتمع كجناح طائر
والطائر لا يستطيع التحليق الا بجناحين
اثنين وكذا المجتمع لا يستطيع التطور
والنمو الا بالرجل والمراه معا حكومه
طالبان علقت تعليم الفتيات في الجامعات
والمدارس فوق الصف السادس الابتدائي وقد
بدات الجامعات قبل 15 يوما امام الذكور
دون الاناث واليوم بدات المدارس هي الاخرى
في جميع البلاد العام الدراسيه دون
الفتيات
بعد شتاء قارص ووصول فصل الربيع ملايين من
براعم مستقبل افغانستان كانت قرارات
طالبان منعت عنها ذلك لتحبس الفتيات خلف
جدران المنازل عبد الاله نادر العربيه
كابول